I don't understand the verdict law we're
exhausted you know and we're
disappointed and you know I never really
had a client quite like Charlie Lynch
and what was the mood of the courtroom
like when the verdict was read they
looked pretty somber surprise to me but
I was so shocked myself I was a little
million Tanaka and guy Iverson SAT with
Lynch as the clerk read the verdict
reuven Cohen and John luttrell the other
two members of the defense team sat at
the same desk the first count was read
guilty luttrell and Cohen each put a
hand on Lynch's shoulder the second
count was read guilty Lynch closed his
eyes tightly it took several minutes for
the clerk to read the verdicts for the
five counts we found mr. Lynch guilty on
all five indictments I think the
majority of us felt like he was a nice
man with good intentions who didn't stay
within the parameters of the federal
wall under the federal law we had no
choice but to find mr. Lynch guilty we
wanted a chance to put on more evidence
until her story and felt like it was
difficult to do that can you talk about
if you felt that the jurors were able to
hear the whole story we heard enough to
make a decision
it's like it's the difference if you
don't know what you didn't hear you
don't know you didn't hear it you know
what I mean we didn't know what we
didn't hear we heard enough to make a
decision on based on what we did here
the entrapment by estoppel how did you
feel about that entrapment by estoppel
was at the heart of Lynch's defense
under the strategy a defendant argues he
broke the law because he was given bad
advice by a government official phone
records show that Lynch made four calls
to various DEA offices prior to opening
his dispensary he says he asked the DEA
what it was going to do about medical
marijuana dispensaries and explained he
was thinking of opening a dispensary of
his own no one from the DEA answered
Lynch's questions until he spoke to a
fifth DEA employee who Lynch says told
him it was quote up to the cities and
counties to decide how they wanted to
handle the matter Lynch assumed this
meant he could operate a dispensary so
long as he abided by local law the
prosecution hammered away at the
entrapment defense and criticized Lynch
for not providing names and titles of
the DEA employees who spoke with him to
not put down who he spoke with or what
position they held made it difficult for
us to
believe that there was entrapment by
estoppel Lynch testified that he would
not have opened a dispensary if the DEA
had told him not to do you think that if
the DEA agent if they had said
explicitly do not under any
circumstances open a medical marijuana
dispensary do you have any sense of what
Charlie would have done with that
information I had the feeling from
something he said that he probably would
not have but I don't we didn't and we
discuss we did not feel it was a DEA
obligation to tell him since it was
already a federal law do we know
anything about what kind of sentence
will be handed down most of the charges
have mandatory minimum prison terms but
whether you know there's always
exceptions to those so we're going to
you know fight as hard as we can to get
around them I think very few people
would think that it's fair to put
Charlie in prison does the jury do they
have any sense of what kind of penalties
Lynch faces now yeah absolutely none
would they think that it would involve
prison time or lots of no idea based on
just all the counts and everything he
could conceivably spend the rest of his
life in prison it you know if that's
what you say I have no idea